comme si de rien n'était il serre des
mains fédé selphy signe des autographes
nicolas sarkozy était dans les yvelines
pour parler éducation après une table
ronde à orgeval avec des professeurs
d'école il s'est rendu à poissy pour
dédicacer son livre tout pour la france
l'occasion pour l'ancien président de la
république de mesurer le soutien
indéfectible de ses partisans aucun
doute aucun doute je toujours confiance
en lui je soutiendrai jusqu'en 2017 je
veux l'aider enfin on peut tous les des
cieux si on rassemble et français oui on
peut les livres je vois pas qui d'autre
peut nous sortir de ce guêpier dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui entre les
attentes des attentes à calais le social
qui nous prend un argent mons rue
aujourd'hui
les subventions des communes qui
disparaissent comme neige qui fond au
soleil voilà donc je pense qu'il ya que
monsieur sarkozy oui aujourd'hui
franchement qui peut faire quelque chose
pour la france soutient également du
côté des élus locaux alors que nicolas
sarkozy a vu son agenda judiciaire se
remplir en début de semaine avec l
annonce de son éventuel renvoi devant le
tribunal dans l' affaire des comptes de
campagne
vous savez les les comptes de monsieur
jospin n'étaient pas exacts dans le sait
maintenant monsieur dumas raconter ça et
le conseil constitutionnel a préféré
regarder ailleurs ça a été la même chose
pour les comptes de monsieur balladur
bon cette histoire de comptes de
campagne ça me paraît être un péché
véniel
les gens font la part des choses voilà
faut arrêter de penser que les gens ne
sont pas capables de voir ne sont pas
capables de voir les les énormes
ficelles
les câbles de tende
la majorité actuelle pour entraver la
route d'un homme vers la présidence
calme serein devant une salle acquise à
sa cause le président des républicains a
tenu à rassurer s'il en était encore
besoin ses partisans rien ne l'empêchera
d'être candidat aucune polémique aucune
manoeuvre
aucune manipulation haution 2 soit 1 ne
me détournera d'un centimètre de ma
volonté absolue de construire avec vous
une alternance forte une alternance
franche une alternance perceptible par
tous les français
avant la présidence nicolas sarkozy
devra passer par la case primaire les
candidats officiels seront connus le 9
septembre pour une élection les 20 et 27
novembre prochains